c'est incroyable donc là soucaille la
caisse tu dis oui là tu te dis voilà
en fait à ce moment là je me rendais pas
compte de la chose parce que pour moi
c'est une journée normale je me rende au
travail je travaille avec au point où je
travaille dans le même établissement que
mon frère est donc je prends l'ascenseur
je vais récupérer la voiture et je pense
que vous entendez le bruit mais d'un
coup en fait j'arrive l'ascenseur
indiqué au moins deux il se bloque et
visions d'horreur en fait j'ai l'eau qui
monte l'eau qui monte et j'entends le
bruit des cascades d'eau qu'on entend
sur les vidéos moi ce moment là je me
rends vraiment pas compte de la gravité
de la chose parce que pour moi c'était
juste je pensais que l'ol allait
m'arriver au tibet à la limite tu basta
et que c'était surtout bloqué j'avais
peur de ça donc j'appelle mon grand
frère un de mes grands frères parce que
j'en ai plusieurs et
je sais même plus ce que je lui dis j'ai
crié je suis bloquée dans l'ascenseur
donc
lui je l'entends partir en courant il
sort de la maison etc et donc je reste
au téléphone avec lui se passe plusieurs
choses entre temps malo qui continue à
monter est ce que je sais c'est que
j'appelle le bouton d'urgence gens qui
sonne et pas de réponse je raisonne
encore une fois pas de réponse à ce
moment là en fait j'étais encore au
téléphone avec mon frère nous montrait
que j'entends courir je l'entends
qui me disent 13 passes où il a quand
même calme cannes cannes et
et moi j'aime trop le dire ce qu'il ya
autour de moi donc à ce moment là je
regarde un peu partout dans l'ascenseur
et je lis les les consignes de sécurité
et loi qu'il fallait rester appuyé
longtemps pour faire sonner la sonnerie
d'urgence donc je fais ça encore une
fois rien et et montrèrent arrive mais
c'est bon soit la sla t'inquiète pas etc
moi j'étais la chambre ryad citée plaît
fais vite séduit tu voyais le goûter
ouais je voyais l'eau monte et comme je
vous ai dit j'aime bien regarder lui
ce qu'il ya autour de moi en temps
normal et là en fait quand je tourne la
tête c'était son ma droite je roulais à
la porte de l'ascenseur et je vois que
de l'oag de la porte en fait 2 duo donc
en face quand je regarde en bas je vois
que l'eau a ri et que l'eau monte et
qu'elle arrive aussi par le haut et
cauchemars c'est à dire mais à ce moment
là c'est pas encore le cauchemar j'avais
extrêmement peur l'a donc votre frère
était venu par l'insee pour assurer vous
avez lu les recommandations voilà de
sécurité les consignes quand vous nous
avez dit le cauchemar là ne fait que
commencer qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ensuite
la convoyer mon frère dans l'eau rien
fait je me posais la question derrière
lolo et à caniveaux et
en fait j'étais au téléphone et gia bhl
l'eau et l'otarie vous parce que l'on ne
voit pas méchant tout petit plus petit
que mon frère quand même il répond pas
il ya blood arrive à quel niveau
enjoy si le nombril et là je craque je
pleure en fait j'ai plus je pleure comme
j'ai jamais pleurer ma vie même mes
frères je pense qu'ils m'ont jamais
entendu chlorés comme ça en fait je
criais je pleure et en fait c'est à ce
moment là où
ou roux je vois la chose arrivait en
fait
c'est bizarre de dire ça mais je me
voyais dans le titanic la scène où l'eau
l'eau monte et que juste ma tête allait
dépasser et
est en fait à ce moment là je me vois
mourir je me dois mourir et quand et
comme mon frère il me dit arrête de
pleurer arrête de pleurer mais est
stressé il essaie d'ouvrir la porte de
l'ascenseur je l'entend crier
et même si j'arrive pas j'y arrive pas
je l'entend crier j'arrive pas j'arrive
pas un maximum moi ce moment là je me
suis dit c'est bon c'est ma faim c'est
ma faim parce qu'à ce moment là derrière
je ne savais pas ce qui se passait je ne
savais pas si les pompiers avaient été
prévenues ou pas mais moi ce moment là
ouais je me sincèrement je me voyais
mourir diable et à vous vous êtes dit
j'ai perdu ma soeur celle ci
au début je suis quelqu'un de nature qui
est pas stressé je pense bien les
émotions vos voix c'est cool vous essayé
de la rassurer donc au début quand je
reçois l'appel moi je pensais qu'elle
est en train de se faire agresser
puisque j'entends crier gare elle
m'appelle le matin je me suis peut-être
au bicycle et où un appel l'homme de
quoi donc je réponds de base
heureusement que je réponds parce que le
matin d'efforts voilà donc je réponds je
réponds aime jouer au moins deux déjà le
capte au moins 2 alors que dans un
ascenseur ce genre à capter mais ici
dans ce bâtiment comme j'aime je sais
pas comment ça pas crise entend du bruit
du site du ca je me dis c'est bon c'est
régresser parce que quelques jours avant
j'ai faim j'ai été témoin d'une feinte
de quelqu'un qui est agressée et c'est
ce qui s'est passé à gré c'est donc je
cours je sois prêt je commence à
comprendre qu'elle est bloquée dans
l'ascenseur qui a de l'eau donc je
réveille mon autre frère en panique je
réveille j'appuie sur sur l'ascenseur
pour la plaie enfin j'avais appelé mais
l'ascenseur mais je dis bon je l'attends
page des samples et je cours déjà j'ai
pas accès au sous sol depuis mon
bâtiment on va te fallait sortir et
avait tout un truc donc là j'ai paniqué
un peu après j'ai fait j'ai pris d'accès
voiture donc par chance par chance le
une chance enfin par chance le gala
porte du garage était cassé donc je
pouvais accéder donc j'ai réussi à gérer
que ça j'ai réussi à accéder au garage
et je la cad l'aud qu'on pouvait voir au
début de la vidéo au niveau du moins en
moins de kim est arrivé au niveau du
mollet moi j'ai dit tranquille c'est ça
j'ai le temps que ça monte avant ça là
quand j'étais au moins un des dix mots
justes aimes-tu peu avant on voit que
c'était juste avant d'ouvrir la porte en
fait je vois que avant d'ouvrir la porte
on voit quand je suis là quand le sol
est jeune on voit que le niveau il
arrive à peu près au passé ça au mollet
donc ici voilà vous y travaille et je me
dis ça va donc je me suis dit ça va 13
pages après des coujoux la porte et cela
se voit waouh je vois toute cette eau là
j'ai dit en fait c'est chaud donc je
panique je descends j'essaie d'ouvrir la
porte de l'ascenseur je pousse toutes
mes forces et j'ai fait je vous entends
puissant parce que l'entend décrier
j'entends les cris et crier et je
poussais de toutes mes forces je me dis
mais y habita de la force pouces je
criais si je me sentais impuissant est
impossible d'ouvrir impossible de vous
lire elle en appelle crie elle qui est
après j'ai entendu crier
et quand j'entends et justement ce qui
fait le plus peur c'est parce qu'elle
crée ça mais je perdrais 100 hommes
stressé mais ça fait peur bien sûr mais
le pire c'est qu'on n'entend plus rien
c'est quand j'entends ce silence complet
j'entends juste pas pas pas j'attende ap
je me dis c'est bon c'est bon à la tête
sous l'eau je me suis dit ça mais en
fait je suis passé elle a trop crié elle
avait plus de voix ou c'est moi avec le
stress j'étais plus jeune a tant déplu
mais j'entendais plus crise j'entendais
juste ap et à ce moment là ce je pense
que j'étais je suis venu de sortie pour
faire repartir pour essayer de passer au
niveau 0 et rejoint notre frère je me
suis dit pendant je courais je fus
j'étais en train de faire le deuil d'une
joie pure et un masseur
jo où elle est morte noyée et où je sais
ma vie c'est ma soeur mary c'est presque
on ma fille un peu on va dire j'allais
souvent responsabilités parce que l'on
est on est du côté de marseille j'allais
souvent allé chez moi donc c'est moi qui
m'occupe de ma mère dans les centres
imminent et je vais je vais là les siens
d'habitude on faisait le trajet du
boulot ensemble tous jeudi la fin je
faisais des qu'est ce que je vais dire à
ma mère comment je vais l'annoncer je
faisais le deuil donc après j'ai reçu à
bord et un pied de biche ah ouais avec
des gens par chance aussi à des gens qui
travaillent le matin sur un chantier
puisque c'était 7h30 du matin on les
fait sont basés là on a pris un pied de
biche on a par contre j'étais arrivé au
niveau zéro donc j'entends des gens
tentaient j'entendais je voulais qualité
a donc on a réussi à apaiser la porte du
niveau zéro avec mon autre frère il y
avait avait aussi un voisin et j'espère
que j'ai sauté du 0 - 2
donc j'étais au dessus donc là j'avais
là je me rends ce débat parce que
justement elle est vivante m'a pris je
pensais que j'avais une trappe n'y avait
pas de trappe qu'est ce que je vais
faire là je me sentais impuissant et là
j'ai ramené mois un tournevis quelque
chose vous tous dévissé vis par vis
je vais faire ça je versailles a pris
jusqu'à un coup je vois je me tourne je
voyais un jour fin juin un peu de lumère
je vois qu'il ya des pompiers qui ont
ouvert la porte et ils voient qu'ils la
sorte comme ça ouais j'ai un nouveau
relâchement en fait c'est un ascenseur
des mentions relâchement là je cours
dans l'eau je vais au parking je saute
dans l'eau je fait j'étais heureux
c'est incroyable malgré elle bravo
pompiers encore
voilà
layar est repoussé que vous êtes né dans
un ascenseur c'est quoi cette histoire
c'est vrai qu'elle est mis dans un
ascenseur sexy c'est vrai donc vous êtes
dit je vais mourir dans un ascenseur
bahia en 1999 dans une petite ville du
sud de la france
j'ai vu le jour dans un ascenseur et la
georgie mais va mais 2022 j'ai vu ma
mort en fait sincèrement ce moment là
même quand mes frères disaient ils
étaient en train ter le deuil mais moi à
ce moment là
vous avez appelé des gens vous avez à
oui j'avais dit aux gens quoi vous avez
dit ça y est je vais en fait c'est
pourquoi j'essaie vidéo parce que j'ai
une story ou où ce film un peu tout ce
qui se passait à ce moment en fait tu
commences à affirmer où je pleure je
sais que c'est débile de faire ça de nos
jours de tout filmer en fait je commence
à filmer ou pour envoyer un message à
mes copines et je supprime est en fait à
ce moment à ce que je fais c'est que
j'en vois juste des messages à des
personnes avec qui sur une dispute en ce
moment et j'ai dix cellules meurent là
sache que je te pardonne car pour moi ce
moment là c'était c'était malsain quand
j'ai su claudette a fait pareil avec
gilles favard
[Rires]
me voyait mourir et je me suis dit au
moins pour moi j'allais vrai un poids
pour pour mes proches et domeo bon ça y
est la 29e tu profites en c'est que
quand il nous arrive un truc comme ça on
va profiter de la vie à fond non mais là
ils peur d'une flaque de l'autre jour
ouais moi elle a eu peur du factor c'est
vrai mais c'est normal elle va avoir sur
alla watts à laquelle va t'en thurella
105 j'ai grandi à côté de loger pour
prend l'ascenseur ou pas il a raison
mais moi non non bien dormi j'ai essayé
de rentrer dans le dans le
rez-de-chaussée du bâtiment j'ai vu là
j'ai vu les ascenseurs cdu csu parti
demeurer pour l'instant c'est nancy
alors au dernier de sa vie qu'elle est
le premier coup de fil que tu as donné
mes frères ce frère ouais j'ai appelé
mes frères parce que pour moi ce moment
là je j'avais j'avais besoin des dés de
réconfort et
si j'ai appelé ma mère si je sais qu au
dernier instant vous rappeler ma mère
parce que ma mère et mon frère masque
sans papiers il se peut qu'on tue les a
pas plus vouloir s'exprimer après parce
que déjà quand j'ai appelé ma mère est
là elle a crié les ailes et en la main
sur des six l'appeler à ce moment là ma
mère je sais qu'elle allait se sentir
impuissant parce qu'elle n'est pas ici
kastali l'appelle son banquier
[Rires]